[Music]
in done [ __ ] up news Oh submitted by
danger Dave a father chased down a thief
and beat him to death with the help of
bystanders oh I love to love this that
sounds pretty extreme what'd he steal
what did he what do you know those steel
sons heart doesn't match the crime
punishment does not match the crime
maybe they got too intense like the mob
mentality yeah because what if someone
stole your sons virginity oh you don't
know what they stole I'd be like I
wouldn't be good sounds like it kind of
founds what you're indicating I don't
know what they stop it what we said so
I'm picturing son be like over 20 for
sure what happened okay like they stole
virginity good for the 2020 he finally
did it all right so this story takes
place in Philly and is it West Philly
border ice cold start okay I want to
know what's happening here so there was
this mom and her boyfriend and three
kids okay there the boyfriend was
working at this pizza shop mmm and so
the boyfriends also the father two of
the kids out of the three so then the
mom ends up running in to the pizza shop
and I don't know what's why she ran in
bushido give her a big kiss probably
leaving her three kids in the this
Hyundai and the kids are aged seven
months 18 months and five years old and
during that time that she left her car
running this 54 year old man oh those
are the car and stole the car with all
three kids in oh [ __ ] Oh so do you guys
would you guys beat to death I got to
hear the rest of the story so then
that's when um both parents who are age
25 they're gonna say like at like track
stars or something oh you're like
running giving everyone's ages so you
can like visualize their energy levels
are much higher than 54 year old yeah
but if you add them together it's 150
year old true mathematically yes still
younger so anyway so then they were able
to catch up because this car became
stuck in track
big they were running on foot yeah on
foot on foot about half a block
yeah and run - am i needed yeah I'm
logic in my disguise looks at driving
half a block God and then there was
traffic so the stop the boyfriend caught
up and there was physical struggle the
who's able to get him out of the car and
then oh I'm sorry
he didn't drive half a block I don't
know how far he drove but after he
caught up to him he the dude end up
running half a block away from the car
that's when the boyfriend caught up and
then struggle and then there were other
males in the neighborhood who began
punching and kicking this guy and he
ended up dying in the hospital later
form severe head and facial injury ok so
that's more nuanced and he probably the
guy probably running after the guy that
jacked the car said he tried to abduct
my kids or something so people jumped in
and then that yeah I mean when kids are
involved do you think he's a pedophile
going for the kids are going for the car
you know what if he was just a thief and
he's like oh I'm a car thief I do I want
these kids you know or what if he was
like I got these kids yeah he took the
kids yeah it's the kids I think it's
because the kids cuz no one wants a
Hyundai that's true oh my god damn
you're a good detective very good
detective
so have you ever driven one by oh I dare
not I dare not get rashes rashes not
want to get in there funky odds are high
all over me [ __ ] oh damn Hyundai hives
you never heard of it
you know the clues
Hyundai hives anyway so both parents
were taking we're taken into custody and
they are cooperating with the
investigation vestigators so they're
saying that the police department's
homicide units and the district
attorney's office will decide if the dad
will face charges it was actually that
it was accidental homicide by the sound
of it obviously and there's bystanders
that participated what what kick led to
the Brandon
see that his kicking led to the death I
think it's fine isn't it like second or
third degree murder or something like
that like it should be tensed agree not
premeditated yeah yeah I know
11th degree [ __ ] that 12 degree murder
that was accidental is also self-defense
you took my kids oh yeah that turns on
another thing he's running after them in
quechua after after he runs away it's
not self-defense any monster so if he
punk you'll have a in the car it'd be
self-defense I would say it's society
self-defense because you know what's
gonna happen is you don't want him to do
this to anyone else for sure to the
point like I mean if this dude died he
must have been [ __ ] up like so [ __ ]
up that I'm wondering like if any of the
guys participating in this beatdown I
stopped and thought to themselves like
who [ __ ] I think it seen I think it's
because they ran past a tap dancing
Academy feel plates on their shoes see
oh that's deadly weapon by a high school
football practice made cleats on soccer
team came out and kicked them yeah the
marching band the stopping artists
Footwear construction workers came out
with their steel toe boots happen in the
concert goers just [ __ ] bouncing on
his brain that's [ __ ] up I think it's
impossible also to prove who dealt that
damage yeah yeah it is
well they look like I skate marks on his
lawyers they're like the pogo stick guy
did it yes the lawyer that guy's lawyers
are on it then he should be like you
know he backed off already you know he's
like he backed off he says he stopped
everyone else kept calling oh it's kind
of some rat [ __ ] nevermind he was senile
he thought it was his car no you cracked
his skull because there was something
that happened in Canada where there was
a fight and then a dude got punched and
then he fell back he was knocked out
and I'd say you go from final
destination ship yeah so you go from
just trying to beat someone up to like
they're dead that's why I don't
understand people when they think like
hey a good clean fight on the street
like it never goes down that way like
you that happens a lot where people just
gets punched and then they're when they
go down their head earlier today you
were talking about how back in the day
in school they would just let people
Duke it out on they form like a circle
like then it's it's kind of like a Fight
Club scenario you're talking you're
talking in the streets or in a bar where
there's a lot of objects and yeah no
I'll talk about that Omar circular to
trust circle to one where everyone gets
together and then they go fight fight
fight
you see those are safe those are fire
that's best computers I never heard
anyone die in that scenario
no yeah cuz bar for how it played out
they go went to the crowd and then they
just like lift them and there's always a
good friend that pushes you behind ya on
both sides yeah extra bit of motivation
yeah it's concrete and weight that does
most people in like the tall you are
just gravity when you crack your skull
or all SN x-u mom you know what that
just made me think of that I recently
read this one story of this woman who
had a metal straw oh no no the Chinese
lady I actually posted so we're saying
this [ __ ] up things I know someone the
witness someone died just crossing the
street oh my god
tripped and fell smack their skull again
on the ground I'm not one of those
stories where it's like well you could
die from leaving your house so matter
might as well not do anything you know
they actually died from leaving their we
know someone that bet that actually got
into a fight outside of a club and died
because she hit her head on a curb yeah
then why don't we put the [ __ ]
concrete makers I'm gonna vote for the
bumper bull thing on all curves a
bowling alley
well you can't get in the gutter cuz the
bumper Bulls me ya curves are killing
people
yeah we need a bad all curves man
in American history eggs for the crew
the curb stomping now they tip you know
you're not that confrontational let's
say someone drove by with Isaac in it
how would you oh [ __ ] I'm running after
the person she's running away after the
car do you think it turns on like this
mom you neither like this guy yeah she
[ __ ] goes like this and she just
starts [ __ ] though she liked assumes
the position and [ __ ] probably run up
all my dreams I don't know why and this
is I think I've actually dreamt about
someone taking Isaac or something
something happened with him and I'm like
trying to run as fast as I can and it
can't run did you got sore already after
20 stuff no but then I end up running on
all fours and I get there fast oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you bar you Ward into a wolf no I
did you bear crawl like the horse girl
that we saw but in my dreams I'm always
running so much faster so I wonder
because my brain is so did you actually
do that
if you ain't going after a car during
work because I saw this lady she was
drunk as [ __ ]
right and she's backed into one of my
co-workers car and then I was like holy
[ __ ] and then she looked outside the
window and she [ __ ] yeah so I like it
ran after her and I was like well I'm
not gonna catch up catch up right so I
was looking at her license plate trying
to remember X Y X because I see whatever
and I was like alright get the name get
the name alright and then or get the
number and I ran back and then I was
just [ __ ] riding that [ __ ] done and I
was like boom this person if I can hit
your car and then they called the cops
and then they somehow found the address
of the person's car and all this [ __ ]
like I guess it's like all in the system
maybe she's done it before like I didn't
do what they went to their house and
they realized she was drunk and yeah she
was scared and [ __ ] that's a happier
ending than this one
dude if anyone did anything to my cat I
would go full John wick that's tight I
wish they did over a dog yeah you're
like that cat like one you have to
though the only one
like the other line rested peace yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]